well a big sigh of relief for thousands
of tenants who were facing eviction
governor sislex's a new eviction
moratorium will expire
on the 31st of march joe mohler is live
outside several apartment complexes
right near maryland sahara
with the reaction tonight joe
the cdc moratorium was set to expire at
the end of the month this new moratorium
will start just after midnight
tonight there are mixed emotions tonight
surrounding this tenants as you can
imagine are
a little less worried but rental
property owners are a bit concerned
but it's at the point now where on the
8th we got a 7 day to pay or quit
spencer howard jr says he was on the
brink of being evicted as the governor
extended the eviction moratorium through
the spring
it's definitely a little bit of an ease
off on my shoulders knowing that they
can't just throw everybody out
like thousands of others he is trying to
navigate his unemployment claim for
benefits
he is filing an appeal but says his
unemployment profile won't work
if i can get my my case reset so that i
can actually
get online to get into my case then i
can file the appeal
this new moratorium put in place in
nevada prohibits evictions but it does
not protect evictions from lease
breaches
for things like unlawful activity or
nuisance the first couple months she
started paying
a couple weeks late every month and then
eventually she just stopped paying it
all together
marissa mastro owns three rental
properties she had a tenant who was
still working in taking advantage of the
last moratorium
when he decided to extend it again
i i almost started crying because it's
so
hard because we have bills too you know
we have mortgages as landlords we have
mortgages
hoas taxes insurance there's nothing to
protect
the landlord
and we also get reaction from the
executive director at the nevada state
apartment association she told us
basically they are worried about this
moving forward
worried about foreclosures as rental
property owners continue to have bills
stacking up as well reporting live joe
mohler 8 news now